welcome to this video playing Michael
player he thought plate the plate him
before but statistics do not confirm
that so that's a new point oh four
nights it's not the most exciting
opening ever g3 yeah it's funny against
g3 the so-called Halloween gambit 90-84
is in fact a playable more come on I'm
going to give that give that a shot he
doesn't seem particularly particularly
shocked in fact many players just ignore
this now and play Bishop g2 not giving
black anymore advances like a 94 f5 it's
quite a good compensation for black now
in fact he gets the material back most
players play Bishop g2 now one
interesting one difference between the
Halloween gambit and this is that after
94 f5 the night does not have a square
gallon g3 okay that's surprising what to
do efore you form
ha ha ha draw offered come on you can't
be serious I just have sacrificed a
piece so what happens here 95 efore
Queenie to I really have no idea i just
i just wanted to have some fun in this
game mmm p for Queenie to probably hmm i
don't know if i want to go a 6
does that work efore Queenie too I don't
see a great move then f5 does d3
I think I've god I do that we returns
the piece that's a surprise night III
wasn't wasn't it I wasn't Lee at all ok
Jack trying to irritate him there with
the chicken and now yeah i can go d 3
that's not bad yeah let's go d 3 that
accelerates my development I guess yeah
night a three I would have played a form
yeah I will show the line afterwards but
night 83 clearly was the critical move I
mean this is play above white it's not
not terribly bad or so but certainly not
the cat most critical option oh he
allows me to keep that porn that is
surprising well it's not threatening to
check it but anyway that looks logical
support that porn
it's not quite clear how he develops b3c
for maybe this kind of thing yeah then
cancelling short a five is an option so
on we should be too i have a four and
this is a somewhat annoying setup or
Bishop b2 Bishop f6 first this is
actually looking better and ce4 it's not
possible now yeah that makes quite some
sense okie dokie 1 going with this I
thought you should have considered rugby
one to have c4 available okay rook e8
orb d8 maybe two da da rupee a team i
just take this going over to e3 jaan
what exactly is the point maybe hmm
okay let's so check that beep horn
yeah I was thinking that this should be
should be interesting it's not in yam
this is the point he's got something to
do for now 95 is also possible move okay
so i move the bishop it's got 95 so i'll
go go here complicated teachers now
always attacked but you might have
captured 94 this is of course dangerous
very tough position
t twangs but he's getting it back with
Ruby one but still there are some issues
with them is a pawn possibly ended my
pawn structure is bad there with the f 5
squared so on but okay is going back
what is he doing then rookie for maybe
hmm maybe try to prevent your key forum
about for up to five rook c8 looks
passive but I really want to get the
beep horn
I really don't know that position is
very very difficult to play time morning
okay I didn't see that one coming how do
i play now Wow hmm didn't see that night
if five I can play that but I'm just
very slow here looking for I guess no
not taking a draw years kind of kind of
risky I didn't see that he can can
actually stop the porn that was my
problem here every didn't see that I
looked it up chatting on yeah what a
shame that was a good position at one
point pretty clearly still going to
fight it's not exactly playing this well
but still a win
yeah all those bad moves didn't help me
okay my resigns I that was bad it was a
really good position around here widest
why does in in some trouble but I
couldn't really make the best out of it
yeah kill the engine just says equal
maybe it is it felt that my pressure on
my on the queenside should be worth
something but I probably did something
wrong and this is this is risky quite
clearly but also interesting should be
593 txt ya around here this is risky but
probably still okay my computer gives
equal all the time I should have played
96 see I didn't really see that move
that was the problem ok major just
probably I should just repeat him but ok
I didn't want to I wanted to wanted to
fight yeah I really didn't see that that
he can that he can stop this oh I'm
actually better here with 94 m 9 its
wasn't possible for me to see this is
dropping it's still hard to believe that
I'm better and also night c5b three ah
that's a very funny idea amazing and
this is purely coincidental I didn't
intend any of that of course no BB 6
intending this and this on etsy 5 p-3
that sits like a slightly better here
huh well didn't didn't see 94 only saw
throw this one yeah and here here I'm
here I'm lost yeah nothing nothing I
could do and there was also a funny
situation in the opening where he played
night b5 and I went here yeah the idea
was said after um yeah this is strange
move right a 3 an idea was that now I
can go here as Queenie too can be
answered with this that was my idea so I
can't castle now this why a 693 had to
be played of course that time was
lacking at the end a little bit but it
was the idea this is a strange move
after that I of course just Jackie Chan
c3f i really wonder could have done
something better here maybe we should be
six instead of Bishop f5 that was
something that wasn't clear to me during
the game as the bishop is certainly
better place only six but I wasn't sure
ever made me need some support for this
now tough tough position thanks for
watching